What does it take to turn Cenobites against each
other? Perhaps even Pinhead's loyal
Chatterer isn't immune to betrayal.
The horrifying Cenobite known as Chatterer has
been a part of the "Hellraiser" franchise since
the very beginning. Even though he was
not referred to by that name, the demon
was featured in the novella that introduced the
Cenobites, "The Hellbound Heart." Author Clive
Barker's description is very close to how the
character would appear in his own film adaptation:
"Its features were so heavily scarified — the
wounds nurtured until they ballooned — that
its eyes were invisible, and its words
corrupted by the disfigurement of its mouth."
One major difference between the original fiction
and the film adaptation is that Chatterer could
actually speak at first, though most likely he
was hard to understand. In the films and comics,
the creature only communicates through the
rather disturbing trademark of clicking
his exposed teeth together instead
of spewing out garbled sentences.
In the first "Hellraiser" film and its sequel,
Chatterer was played by Nicholas Vince,
who made his screen debut with the role. According
to Paul Kane, author of "The Hellraiser Films and
Their Legacy," Vince was a drama student enrolled
at Mountview Theatre School in London when he met
Clive Barker. One of Vince's classmates was Simon
Bamford, who was a member of Barker's theater
group, the Dog Company. Bamford would later accept
a role as one of the Cenobites, and it was through
him that Vince met Barker at a party, which led to
a discussion about working together shortly after.
In an interview with Devolution Magazine, Vince
briefly described his working relationship
with Barker during the years leading up to
the production of the iconic horror flick:
"I ended up modeling for the covers of 'Books
of Blood' and I think I'm on four out of six,
either my head or bits of my body. So, Clive
had known me for nearly three years by the
time 'Hellraiser' came about. He knew
I could do physical stuff so he said,
'Would you like to be in a movie?
There is some makeup involved.'"
As it turned out, that was
something of an understatement.
"The box. You opened it. We came."
Almost nothing is known about Chatterer
until the second film, "Hellbound:
Hellraiser 2," which features a brief glimpse
of what the creature looked like as a human
before his horrific transformation. After
the film's evil doctor antagonist mutates
into the powerful Channard Cenobite, he faces
off against Pinhead and his demon followers,
including Chatterer. Even though Channard
is outnumbered, he slays each foe,
which reveals their past forms. That's
when we see Chatterer as a young boy.
When talking with Devolution Magazine, actor
Nicholas Vince admitted he was upset at first
about the way that scene was captured on film.
But as he fleshed out his own backstory for
the character, he became more intrigued by
the concept of a child Cenobite. He said,
"I realize I was really pissed off that the
moment Chatterer changes you didn't get to see me,
you got to see a boy. Over the years I found the
idea of a boy growing up in hell fascinating. All
the other Cenobites are revealed to be adults, but
a boy? That whole idea was really interesting."
Once Chatterer had become a member of Pinhead's
entourage, one of his early victims was the
celebrity Janice Baur. In the short story
"Losing Herself in the Part" from "Clive
Barker's Hellraiser" #8, the actress rejects
a role offered by director Steven Sigourney
because she cannot relate to the level of pain
her character has gone through. In response,
Sigourney hands her the Lament Configuration
and asks her to carry out an acting exercise
with it by getting the puzzle box into the
Shape of Pain. Intrigued by this new method,
she takes the box home and works on it right away.
Baur's fascination turns dark quickly as she
cuts her hands for days to solve the puzzle. She
also begins to have vivid nightmares of Hell. Her
descent into madness made her feel ready to accept
the part, but that's when the Lament Configuration
opens and sends the actress into Hell. There,
she is tortured by Chatterer and the other
Cenobites while Sigourney films it all. Baur
then continues to act in films, but her life is
dominated by the creatures of Hell from then on.
In "Hellraiser Nightbreed: Jihad" #1 and #2,
the Cenobites initially confront the Nightbreed
in an epic crossover showdown between two of
Clive Barker's most popular universes. However,
before long it becomes clear that Alastor,
the Cenobite waging war on the Nightbreed,
intends to carry out a complete purge of
his foe, which defies Leviathan's will.
In response, the God of Pain and Pleasure orders
Chatterer and Pinhead to destroy the heretic
and his followers. When the demonic warriors
encounter Alastor and his Cenobite entourage,
he's quickly abandoned by all his followers
except for his lover Chalkis, who is bound
to him with a golden chain. Once the couple is
defeated, Leviathan reverts them to their human
bodies and the two are hunted down by one of the
Nightbreed that they had tried to exterminate.
Pinhead has several followers in his demonic
crew throughout the "Hellraiser" series,
but Chatterer is often depicted as the
leader's top lieutenant among the Cenobites.
He has appeared in more "Hellraiser" films
than any of the others, aside from Pinhead,
so the character has a prominent spot
within the nightmarish universe. Even so,
this didn't save him from the
cruel wrath of his leader.
"Your suffering will be legendary. Even in hell."
While the first Chatterer was killed off in the
second film, he was resurrected 20 years later by
Pinhead in the "Hellraiser" comic series. Pinhead
himself was revived once the Pillar of Souls was
fed blood in "Hellraiser 3: Hell on Earth," so
their master used the same method to bring back
Chatterer and the Female Cenobite with bloodshed
on the very spot where they had met their demise.
Later, in the fifth chapter of
"Clive Barker's Hellraiser Omnibus",
Pinhead and the Cenobites confront Kirsty
Cotton again and have her in their grasp.
Yet instead of taking the heroine out, Pinhead
traps his own followers in his chains despite
their pleas. He then hands Kirsty a knife and
she uses it to slay the Cenobite once more.
Pinhead may have been directly responsible
for the second death of his servant in "Clive
Barker's Hellraiser Omnibus," but another
tale shows how Chatterer finally achieved
gruesome revenge for the betrayal. Over a decade
before Gary Tunnicliffe directed the tenth film,
"Hellraiser: Judgment," he released a
short fan flick in 2004 called "No More
Souls," which could be considered
official canon for the series.
The story takes place in the distant future after
humanity has destroyed itself and Hell no longer
has any souls to reap. In desperation over the
depletion of such a valuable resource, Pinhead
opens the Lament Configuration to sacrifice
himself. The Cenobites then emerge to slay their
master, and Chatterer nails Pinhead's ripped-off
face to a Torture Pillar, signifying his true end.